hello everyone
welcome to another interesting video by
simply learn
as you know the graphical variation of
data constitutes a discipline within the
data science universe
this practice has become an important
milestone throughout the history in data
analytics
so keeping that in mind in this video we
are going to discuss an important graph
that is a boss in the risk of plot
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
so let's discuss the agenda for this
tutorial
we'll begin this video by discussing
what is box and whisker plot
and some important terms involved with
the box and whisker plot
after this we'll look into the way in
which you can construct a box and a
visco plot by taking an example
after this we will move on to the python
and see how you can create a box and a
visual plot
so without further ado let's get started
so what are box and whisker plot
a box in a viscous plot is a graphical
representation of variation in a set of
data
a histogram analysis is usually
sufficient but a box in a list of plot
can add more detail
while also allowing multiple sets of
data to be displayed in the same graph
let us understand the terms involved
here
so the first one is the minimum value is
the smallest value
in the data set the q1 which is the
lower quartile
is the value below which the lower 25
percent of the data are contained
the median value is a middle number in a
range of numbers
the q3 which is also the third quartile
is the value over which the about 25
percent of the data are contained
and at last the maximum value which is
largest value in the data set
now that we know about what is box and
whisker plots
and the key terms that are required to
construct a plot let's move on to an
example to see how you can construct a
plot in the systematic manner
here we have a sample age of 10 students
at a training center
so the first step would be to arrange
the data in the ascending order the
second step is to find the median of the
data set
since there are even number of terms
we'll find the average of the middle two
terms
to find the average of the data set so
adding 20 plus 24 and dividing it by 2
we get the average as 22
which is also the median of our data
side
now that we have find our median of the
data set let's move on to the next step
so the next step is to find the median
of the lower half and the upper half
the lower half median is 19 which is
also the q1 of the data set and the
upper half median is 25 which is the q3
of the data set
so our five number summary will look
like this
the minimum value is 15 the q1 is 19
the median which is also the q2 is 22
and the upper half meter is 25
and finally the maximum value which is
28
now we have all the required values to
make a box plot so let's go ahead and
create one
so to create the box plot the first step
would be to make a number line to the
proper scaling
after this you just have to draw the
whisker from q1 to the minimum
and q3 to the maximum age value now that
we have created
the box plot let's understand what these
value
actually means so the lowest age among
the students at the training center is
15
excluding the outliers about 25
students are under 19 years of age and
close to 50 percent of the students are
between 19 and 25 years of age
nearly 75 percent of the students have
an age less than 25
and the maximum age among the students
is 28 extremely outlaws
now that we know how to create a box
plot let's move on to python compiler to
see how you can create a box plot using
a matplot and a numpy library
so here i am on an online compiler so
let's start by importing
matplotlib and numpy library
i plot as plot
import numpy as
np now that we have imported both the
libraries
let's generate some random numbers
for that we use the function random
so np dot random and will limit random
integers
so the first value we are going to enter
is the lowest value our data set can
have
so 0 the 100 will be the maximum value
the data set can have
and there should be 100 terms in our
data set
now to make a box plot just use the plot
dot box plot function and pass it to
sequence
make sure you spell it right now
to get the graph use plot dot show now
just run it
you can see we have our box plot ready
so in this way you can create the box
plot in a python
so with this we come to an end of this
tutorial
in conclusion you can summarize the data
from multiple sources and display a
result in a single graph
which other graph and visualization
method do you feel is useful let us know
in the comment section below
thank you for being here and watching
for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here